[Música]
ya comenzó el Roland garros uno de los
cuatro grandes torneos del circuito
profesional es de tenis la cita
Deportiva en tierra batida este año no
cuenta con la participación de su máximo
campeón el 14 veces vencedor Rafael
Nadal quien optó por cuidar su salud de
cara al 2024 que bien Podría ser su
último año como pro cómo cambia el
ambiente del torneo y las posibilidades
en su ausencia vamos a conversar sobre
este tema con Alejandro siriza él es
corresponsales de tenis del diario del
país y también autor del libro vamos
Rafa Alejandro gracias a usted por estar
con nosotros y nos acompaña también el
periodista deportivo Juan pupiales Buen
día para usted
Hola qué tal Muy buenas tardes desde
aquí desde París desde Roland garros
Bueno quiero empezar preguntándole y ya
que usted está allá viviendo lo todo en
directo
que genera la ausencia de Rafa Nadal en
los demás tenistas se podría hacer el
papel de potenciarlos o de bajar su
ánimo de Cara a la competencia
bueno la sensación que predomina ahora
mismo aquí en París es una sensación
extraña no por primera vez de 2005 no no
está Nadal y todos sabemos lo que
significa Nadal para este torneo con lo
cual hay una especie de de vacío
emocional no que estamos viviendo Y
percibiendo estos primeros días
aún así no obstante para el resto de los
jugadores de los competidores se abre
una puerta que hasta ahora estaba
cerrada por por Rafa con lo cual nos
encontramos ante un torneo completamente
nuevo novedoso con con muchas más más
alternativas y relativamente incierto
hay varios favoritos está ahí Alcaraz
está yokovich pero desde este momento en
el momento que no está Rafa la verdad es
que el abanico se abre muchísimo y bueno
va a ser distinto pero desde luego va a
ser un torneo muy muy emocionante y con
muchas ganas de vivirlo por supuesto
hay un elemento importante a la hora de
la ausencia de ráfagal frente a los
rivales a Los favoritos que ya
mencionabas es ese papel de tratar de
consolidarse Carlos ya todo el mundo
Espera que ellos ganen Cómo afecta eso a
un tenista ya ese papel en Roland garros
ya no está Rafa ya las miradas se ponen
sobre ellos es un deportista como le
afecta al nivel de tener que
consolidarse demostrar efectivamente yo
estoy incapacidad de ganar ese torneo
Bueno pues es una prueba de máxima
exigencia psicológica de máxima
exigencia mental para para todos y cada
uno de ellos especialmente de los de los
aspirantes en el instante en el que no
está Nadal ese porcentaje de atención
que es que es inmenso que hay sobre Rafa
estos días aquí en París recae sobre
ellos con lo cual bueno se trata de un
de un complejo ejercicio de equilibrios
de cómo gestionar de cómo procesar todo
ese tipo de emociones ese tipo de
favoritismo que ahora recae sobre ellos
y la verdad es que es verdaderamente
complejo no tanto en el caso de yo
Djokovic porque es un jugador muy
veterano que ha ganado 22 grandes que
tiene un recorrido larguísimo a sus
espaldas pero sí En realidad en el caso
de Carlos Alcaraz recordemos que lleva
prácticamente tres años solo en el
circuito Es verdad que ha crecido muy
rápido que está madurando a marchas
forzadas pero no deja de ser un chico de
20 años que de repente se encuentra con
toda la presión encima estamos todos los
focos y todos los medios tenemos
depositados los ojos sobre él con lo
cual vamos a ver qué respuesta tiene
tiene Carlos es una prueba de nivel no
solo tenístico sino fundamentalmente una
prueba de nivel mental y de madurez
mental
Bueno también quiero preguntarle
pensando en esta ausencia de Rafael
Nadal porque claro los Lo vamos a
extrañar como fans Cuál será Su futuro
en el circuito Usted cree que va a
lograr Volver al Roland garros
Bueno es es también absolutamente
incierto la intención o el plan inicial
de Nadal de Rafa pasa por tratar de
volver aquí el año pasado el año que
viene Ese es su plan inicial otra cosa
es lo que lo que dictamine su cuerpo él
ahora mismo necesita un periodo de reset
necesita recargar pilas tanto física
como mentalmente Y a partir de ahí a ir
aprobando las opciones lo veremos con el
tiempo yo creo que debemos ir tener Pues
bueno pies de plomo y debemos huir muy
día a día en su caso porque su cuerpo
bueno tiene 37 años está muy castigado
por las lesiones va a tratar de
regenerarlo pero la respuesta va a ser
va a tener que ser del día a día y es lo
que nos dirá si si el día de mañana
puede volver puede regresar aquí a París
yo creo desde luego y esto es una
opinión personal pero desde luego creo
que sería el marco el marco excepcional
o el marco idóneo para que él para que
él se despiece del tenis pero bueno
Luego veremos lo que quiere hacer él
quiere despedirse de diferentes espacios
de diferentes torneos de diferentes
ciudades en las que ha recibido todo el
cariño del público Pero por supuesto que
en el caso de París seguro que está
seguro que está señalado con rojo y
puede o no lo veremos lo dirá su cuerpo
seguramente gran parte de los esfuerzos
de Rafa para la próxima temporada si van
a centrar en llegar bien a ese Roland
garros del próximo año llevamos apenas
dos días de torneo pero te quería
preguntar cuál es el sentir allá en el
torneo de este Roland garros sin Rafa
Nadal Roland garros un torneo francés
que ha visto como su máximo campeón es
español y es una figura ya muy querida
allí ya en París
bueno las sensaciones es muy distinta
Hay un sentimiento de no voy a decir de
relativo de orfandad no está lo titulaba
el equipo Hace unos días decía una una
tierra sin su Rey pues es un poco la
sensación que predomina ahora mismo aquí
no está Rafa todo es un poco distinto la
energía un poco la energía emocional que
existe en las instalaciones es distinta
porque porque Rafa al final es un gran
generador de energías y de emociones y
especialmente aquí en París y digamos
que existe un sentimiento de nostalgia
la gente está la gente triste ver a
nadar jugar en la en la philipsa pie
aquí es es algo excepcional es algo
distinto es algo diferente no está él y
todo cambia no vamos a ver si si ahora
estos jugadores que de los que
hablábamos el propio Carlos o el propio
Nova y Djokovic son capaces de llenar el
vacío pero la verdad es que la sensación
de que hay ahora mismo que predomina
Aquí estos días es eso una sensación de
relación es muy distinto el torneo
Orland garros es Rafa Nadal y Rafa Nadal
garros con lo cual las sensaciones
completamente distinta finalmente
Alejandro para ir completamente a lo que
es su opinión y su haber deportivo
dentro del Roland garros Cuáles son para
usted los y las más peligrosos en este
torneo
Bueno yo sí Me tengo que mojar si tengo
que apostar por alguien de entrada lo
haría por por Carlos Alcaraz Por qué
Carlos Alcaraz porque Carlos Alcaraz es
el que mejor que ha completado una mejor
gira de tierra Hasta ahora ha ganado
tres torneos en otro llegó a la final
ganó en Barcelona en Madrid en dos
Marcos que son ya son importantes son de
envergadura y yo creo que ahora mismo
hoy por hoy sobre tierra batida sobre
arcilla el nivel su niveles superior al
de los demás veremos cuál es la
respuesta mental cuál es la respuesta
física en el caso de Djokovic es yokovic
seguro que va a tener Pues bueno se
enreda estos primeros días seguro es
verdad que viene relativamente tocado
venía con algún problema físico que
parece haber superado pero el otro día
dejó en la rueda de prensa inicial unos
mensajes con un poco de incertidumbre de
no excesiva convicción y eso nos nos
hace dudar veremos también cuál es la
respuesta y en cuanto a las chicas yo
creo que aquí harina zabalenca Es la que
ahora mismo Está en mejor estado de
forma habrá que ver también la respuesta
de DJ biontech que ha ganado dos veces
aquí que Pues bueno tiene un juego muy
poderoso sobre sobre polvo de ladrillo
bueno Está todo todo abierto pero pero
en el caso de tener que mencionar
algunos nombres citaría esos cuatro
nombres como los principales aspirantes
sin duda pues es Alejandro sirisa
corresponsales de tenis del diario El
País y autor del libro vamos Rafa Muchas
gracias a usted Muchísimas gracias por
la invitación un placer Saludos desde
aquí Bueno gracias También a usted 10
minutos ya volvemos con más noticias
deportivas si le parece aquí estaremos
Claro que sí entre tanto vamos a hacer
la pausa y ya regresamos con más
titulares
[Música]